we're going to begin with preparations
for that massive nor'easter that could
slam the east coast this weekend
forecasters are expecting blizzard-like
conditions including high winds low
visibility and heavy heavy snowfall it
could be the largest nor'easter in years
and we're going to have team coverage
including a look at the all-important
track of the storm from stephanie abrams
of the weather channel but first let's
go to mola lenghi who's at
nada natasket beach that's on
massachusetts bay where more than a foot
of snow is expected to fall mola good
morning to you
good morning tony today folks we're
waking up to a cold but common new
england morning but by this time sunday
it's expected to look and feel very
different as folks gear up for what
could be the biggest winter storm of the
season this area here along the
massachusetts coastline forecasters are
predicting around two feet of snow
coastal residents who are well initiated
to this sort of thing they are used to
it
they've been around for a while but
still they are boarding up their homes
those who have boats are bringing in
their boats as the winter blast could
cause storm surge with some moderate
flooding about 40 minutes from boston
the town of scituate massachusetts is
encouraging voluntary evacuations while
handing out sandbags and preparing
emergency vehicles across the region
snow plows are ready to go but
many of the cleanup crews are operating
with reduced step partly because of the
pandemic one local crew for example is
working with just half of the usual team
which obviously means that it could take
longer for the roads to be cleared as
the storm continues to move officials
say be prepared
monitor this storm do what you need to
do even for those who are well initiated
good to track the storm keep an eye out
on it and be ready
gail
okay mola thanks